(HOST) IRA GLASS: OK. So let's all just pause here for a second for something that is so rare on public radio or, you know, I guess, anywhere, actually. Let's pause for something that everyone can agree on. Something that doesn't divide Republicans and Democrats, Sunni and Shia, Taylor Swift fans and Katy Perry fans.
好的。那么我们现在先暂停一下，来聊聊一件在公共广播，或者说在任何地方，都非常罕见的事情。让我们先暂停一下，来聊聊一件大家都能达成共识的事情。一件不会引发共和党人和民主党人、逊尼派和什叶派、泰勒·斯威夫特粉丝和凯蒂·佩里粉丝之间争论的事情。
This something that I found like that everybody can agree on is a graphic. It's a graphic that somebody showed me on the internet. It's an optical illusion created by a professor at MIT who studies vision and the brain.
我发现的这件大家都能达成共识的事情，是一张图表。这张图表是有人在网上给我看的。这是一个由麻省理工学院的一位研究视觉和大脑的教授所创作的视觉错觉图。
And basically, there are two gray boxes. One of them is surrounded by lighter stuff so it looks darker, and the other gray box is surrounded by darker stuff so it looks lighter. But in fact, the whole point of it is it's an optical illusion. The two gray squares are exactly the same shade of gray.
简单来说，图上有两个灰色方块。其中一个被较浅的颜色包围，所以看起来较深；另一个灰色方块被较深的颜色包围，所以看起来较浅。但实际上，它的全部意义在于这是一种视觉错觉。这两个灰色方块的灰色深浅是完全一样的。
Now, that's just a fact. But of course, since this graphic is on the internet, there's a comment section. And you might think, what would you possibly comment on? Right?
现在，这只是一个事实。但当然，由于这张图是在互联网上，所以下面有评论区。你可能会想，这种事情有什么可评论的呢？对吧？
It doesn't seem like there's anything, really, here to discuss. Gray is gray. And I'll refrain from a Fifty Shades of Gray joke here and just say, when you scroll down through the comments, people do find a way to disagree, even about this.
这里似乎真的没什么好讨论的。灰色就是灰色。我就不在这里讲“五十度灰”的冷笑话了，我只想说，当你往下滚动评论区时，人们确实能找到反驳的理由，即使是针对这种事情。
And I don't know, maybe you've been on the internet-- they like to curse about it. One person writes, "what a load of shit. They are different colors." Another writes, "not the same [BEEP] shade." Says a third, "not convinced."
我不知道，也许你也上过网——他们喜欢为此咒骂。有人写道：“简直是胡扯，它们颜色就是不一样。”另一个人写道：“根本不是同一种[哔]颜色。”第三个人说：“我才不信。”
Then people start in with advice. And at first, they're like, super nice about it, right? They're trying to be helpful. They tell the doubters to take their fingers and cover over everything but the two gray squares on their screen and they'll see they are the same color.
接着，人们开始提供建议。起初，他们表现得超级友好，对吧？他们试图提供帮助。他们告诉怀疑者，用手指遮住屏幕上除那两个灰色方块以外的所有部分，他们就会看到这两个方块是同一种颜色。
Several people suggested they can open up the file on Photoshop or MS Paint and use the Dropper tool to see the exact RGB values of the colors and they'll see that they're the same. By the way, 120, 120, 120 with 160 hue, 113 loom.
有几个人建议他们可以把图片在 Photoshop 或 MS Paint 中打开，然后使用吸管工具来查看颜色的精确 RGB 数值，这样他们就能看到它们是一样的。顺便说一下，数值是 120, 120, 120，色调 160，亮度 113。
After all of that, somebody still writes, "The second square looks brighter to me." Somebody else replies, "It's definitely brighter than you." People start calling each other stupid, which of course leads to the kind of big, overbroad, sweeping statement you see in comment sections everywhere. Quote, "If after reading this thread, you refuse to actually test it and choose to stick with your dogmatic belief, then you are everything that is wrong with America."
经历这一切之后，还是有人写道：“第二个方块在我看来更亮。”另一个人回复说：“你肯定比它还亮。”人们开始互相谩骂，这当然会导致你在评论区随处可见的那种大规模、笼统、一概而论的断言。引用一句：“如果在阅读了这些帖子之后，你拒绝亲自去验证，并选择坚持你那种教条的信仰，那么你就是美国所有问题的根源。”
You know, I think we're all so used to all kinds of ugliness online in comment sections and Twitter and Facebook and everywhere else. At this point, most of us don't even give it a second thought. And so today on our radio show, we decided, well, let's give it a second thought.
你知道，我觉得我们都已经习惯了网络评论区、推特、脸书和其他所有地方的各种丑陋现象。到了现在，我们大多数人甚至连想都不会多想一下。所以今天在我们的广播节目中，我们决定，嗯，让我们多想一下。
Let's dive into the bile. Let's dive into the hate and look around and see whatever we can understand. Let's ask the dumbest questions. Like, why so mad? And if you are so mad, why go to the trouble to tell strangers how mad you are?
让我们深入了解这些戾气。让我们深入这些仇恨，环顾四周，看看我们能理解些什么。让我们问些最笨的问题。比如，为什么要这么生气？如果你这么生气，为什么还要费尽心思去告诉陌生人你有多生气？
From WBEZ Chicago, this is an hour of stories with some very upset, anonymous people who we get to know a little bit. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是一小时的故事集，讲述了一些我们稍作了解的、非常愤怒的匿名人士的故事。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act one, "Ask Not for Whom the Bell Trolls. It Trolls for Thee." Let's begin with the worst case scenario of things that can happen on the internet with a troll. In fact, a kind of exceptional troll. Trolls, of course, are people who post hate and abuse online. They use comments sections in social media to hound people and shriek at people.
第一幕，“莫为丧钟谁人鸣，它为你而鸣。”让我们从互联网上可能发生的最糟糕的喷子事件说起。事实上，是一种特别恶劣的喷子。当然，喷子就是那些在网上发布仇恨和辱骂信息的人。他们利用社交媒体的评论区去纠缠和尖叫攻击他人。
Studies show that both men and women are harassed online, but women get way more malicious messages. And they're way more likely to be stalked online or sexually harassed. Lindy West is a writer who's written for a lot of places like Jezebel and GQ and The Guardian . Her work is online, so she is very familiar with internet trolls and she has our story.
研究表明，无论男性还是女性都会在网上受到骚扰，但女性会收到更多恶意信息。她们也更有可能在网上被跟踪或受到性骚扰。林迪·韦斯特是一位作家，曾为 Jezebel、《GQ》和《卫报》等许多媒体供稿。她的作品在网上发布，所以她对网络喷子非常了解，接下来由她来讲述我们的故事。
Quick warning to podcast listeners. From this point forward, we are not going to beep anything in today's show. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Here's Lindy.
给播客听众一个简短的警告。从现在起，我们今天的节目将不再对任何词语进行消音。如果你更喜欢消音版本，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。下面有请林迪。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: One midsummer afternoon in 2013, I got a message on Twitter from my dead dad. I don't remember what it said exactly and I didn't keep a copy for my scrapbook, but it was mean. And my dad was never mean, so it couldn't really be from him. Also, he was dead.
2013 年仲夏的一个下午，我收到了一条来自我已故父亲的推特信息。我不记得确切内容了，我也没有保留备份，但那条信息很刻薄。我父亲从不刻薄，所以那不可能是他发的。而且，他已经去世了。
Just 18 months earlier, I'd watched him turn gray and drown in his own lungs. So I was, like, 80% sure. And I don't believe in heaven. And even if I did, I'd hope to god they don't have fucking Twitter there. It's heaven. Go play chocolate badminton on a cloud with Jerry Orbach and your childhood cat.
就在 18 个月前，我看着他脸色灰败，死于肺部积水。所以我百分之 80 确定。而且我不相信天堂。即使我信，我也祈祷上帝保佑天堂里没有该死的推特。那是天堂啊。去和杰瑞·奥巴赫（Jerry Orbach）以及你童年的猫在云端玩巧克力羽毛球吧。
But there was a message. Some context. In the summer of 2013, in certain circles of the internet, comedians and feminists were at war over rape jokes. Being both a comedy writer and a committed feminist killjoy, I weighed in with an article in which I said that I think a lot of male comedians are careless with the subject of rape.
但确实有那条信息。背景是这样的：2013 年夏天，在互联网的某些圈子里，喜剧演员和女权主义者就强奸笑话展开了战争。作为一个既是喜剧作家又是坚定的女权主义“扫兴者”，我发表了一篇文章，说我认为许多男喜剧演员在强奸这个话题上非常不负责任。
Here's just a sample of the responses I got on social media. A quick warning-- these are internet comments about rape, so it's going to suck. "I love how the bitch complaining about rape is the exact kind of bitch that would never be raped." "Holes like this make me want to commit rape out of anger." "I just want to rape her with a traffic cone."
以下是我在社交媒体上收到的一些回应。一个小小的警告——这些是关于强奸的网络评论，所以内容会很糟糕。“我很喜欢那个抱怨强奸的婊子，她那种人根本就不会被强奸。”“像这种洞（holes）让我想因为愤怒而去强奸。”“我只想用交通锥去强奸她。”
"No one would want to rape that fat, disgusting mess." "Kill yourself." "I want to put an apple into that mouth of yours and take a huge stick and slide it through your body and roast you." "That big bitch is bitter that no one wants to rape her."
“没人会想要强奸那个肥胖、令人恶心的垃圾。”“去死吧。”“我想把苹果塞进你那张嘴里，然后拿根大棍子穿过你的身体，把你烤了。”“那个肥婆真是因为没人想强奸她而感到痛苦。”
It went on like that for weeks. It's something I'm used to. I have to be. Being insulted and threatened online is part of my job, which is not to say it doesn't hurt. It does. It feels, well, exactly like you'd imagine it would feel to have someone call you a fat cunt every day of your life.
这样的言论持续了数周。我已经习惯了。我不得不习惯。在网上受到侮辱和威胁是我工作的一部分，这并不是说它不伤人。它确实伤人。这种感觉，好吧，就像你想象中每天被人叫“肥胖的荡妇”那样。
When I got that message from my dad, it was well into rape joke summer. I was eating 30 rape threats for breakfast at that point. Or more accurately, "you're fatter than the girls I usually rape" threats. And I thought I was coping. But if you get a blade sharp enough, it'll cut through anything.
当我收到我父亲发来的那条信息时，那场强奸笑话之夏的争论已经持续了很久。那时我早餐都要“吃掉”30 条强奸威胁。或者更准确地说，“你比我通常强奸的那些女孩还要胖”这种威胁。我以为我在应对。但如果刀锋足够锋利，它能切开任何东西。
The account was called PawWestDonezo. Paw West because his name was Paul West. And Donezo because, I guess, he was done. He was done being alive, done doing crossword puzzles, done forcing me to sing duets at dinner parties. Done writing little poems on the back of every receipt. Done being my dad.
那个账号叫“PawWestDonezo”。“Paw West”是因为他叫保罗·韦斯特（Paul West）。“Donezo”是因为，我想，他结束了。他结束了生命，不再做填字游戏，不再强迫我在晚宴上和他合唱二重唱。不再在每一张收据背面写小诗。不再做我的父亲。
The little bio on Twitter read, "embarrassed father of an idiot." Other two kids are fine, though. His location-- dirt hole in Seattle. The profile photo was a familiar picture of him. He's sitting at his piano smiling in the living room of the house where I grew up.
推特的个人简介上写着：“一个白痴的尴尬父亲。不过另外两个孩子还不错。”他的所在地是——西雅图的一个土坑。头像是我父亲的一张熟悉照片。他正坐在客厅的钢琴前微笑着，那是我长大的房子。
The day they sold that house, when I was 25, I sat on the stairs and sobbed harder than I ever had before. Because a place is kind of like a person, you know? It felt like death. I wouldn't cry that hard again until December 12, 2011, when I'd learn that a place is not like a person at all. Only a person is a person. Only a death is really a death.
我 25 岁那年，他们卖掉了那栋房子，我坐在楼梯上哭得比以往任何时候都伤心。因为一个地方就像一个人，你懂吗？那种感觉就像死亡。直到 2011 年 12 月 12 日，当我得知一个地方根本不像人时，我再也没有那样哭过。只有人才是人。只有死亡才是真正的死亡。
My dad lost consciousness on a Saturday night. That afternoon, when we could feel his lucidity slipping, we called my brother in Boston. You were such a special little boy, he said. I love you very much. He didn't say very many things after that. I would give anything for one more sentence. I would give anything for 140 more characters.
我父亲在周六晚上失去了知觉。那天下午，当我们感觉到他的神智开始模糊时，我们给波士顿的哥哥打了电话。父亲说：“你是个特别的孩子。我非常爱你。”之后他没再说太多话。我愿意付出一切换取他再多说一句话。我愿意付出一切换取他再多写 140 个字符。
The person who made the PawWestDonezo account clearly put some time into it. They'd researched my father and my family. They'd found out his name.
创建“PawWestDonezo”账号的人显然花了不少时间。他们研究了我的父亲和我的家庭。他们查到了他的名字。
And then they figured out which Paul West he was among all the Paul Wests on the internet. They knew that I have a brother and a sister. And if they knew all that, they must have known how recently we'd lost my dad.
然后他们弄清楚了在互联网上所有的保罗·韦斯特中，哪一位才是我的父亲。他们知道我有哥哥和姐姐。如果他们知道这些，他们肯定也知道我们失去父亲才过去没多久。
Conventional wisdom says never feed the trolls. Don't respond. It's what they want. I do that. It doesn't help.
传统智慧告诉我们，永远不要喂食喷子。不要回应。那是他们想要的。我照做了。但这并没有什么帮助。
I could just stop reading comments altogether, but sometimes I get threatening ones. Like the other day, someone said I should get Charlie Hebdoed. Colleagues of mine have had their addresses published online, had trolls actually show up in person at their public events. If I don't read comments, how will I know when they've crossed the line?
我可以彻底不再看评论，但有时我会收到威胁性的评论。比如前几天，有人说我应该遭遇《查理周刊》那样的袭击。我的同事曾被公开住址，喷子甚至亲自出现在他们的公开活动现场。如果我不看评论，我怎么知道他们什么时候越界了呢？
I could just stop writing altogether. I've thought about it. But it seems to me that our silence is what the trolls want.
我可以彻底停止写作。我也想过。但在我看来，沉默正是喷子们想要的。
Faced with PawWestDonezo, I was stuck with the question, what should I do? If I respond, I'm a sucker. But if I don't respond, I'm a punching bag.
面对“PawWestDonezo”，我陷入了一个问题：我该怎么办？如果我回应，我就是个傻瓜。如果我不回应，我就是个出气筒。
So I did what you're not supposed to do. I fed the troll. I wrote about PawWestDonezo in an article for Jezebel.com. I wrote sadly, candidly, angrily about how much it hurt. How much that troll had succeeded.
所以我做了不该做的事。我喂食了喷子。我在 Jezebel.com 的一篇文章中写到了“PawWestDonezo”。我悲伤、坦诚且愤怒地写道，这对我伤害有多大。那个喷子有多成功。
And then something amazing happened. The morning after that post went up, I got an email. "Hey, Lindy, I don't know why or even when I started trolling you. It wasn't because of your stance on rape jokes. I don't find them funny, either.
然后发生了一件令人惊奇的事。在那篇文章发表后的第二天早上，我收到了一封电子邮件。“嘿，林迪，我不知道我为什么甚至是什么时候开始喷你的。那不是因为你对强奸笑话的立场。我也不觉得它们好笑。
I think my anger towards you stems from your happiness with your own being. It offended me because it served to highlight my unhappiness with my own self. I have emailed you through two other Gmail accounts just to send you idiotic insults. I apologize for that.
我想我对你的愤怒源于你对自我存在的快乐。这冒犯了我，因为它突显了我对自己生活的不快乐。我通过另外两个 Gmail 账号给你发过邮件，只是为了发送愚蠢的侮辱。对此我表示道歉。
I created the [email protected] account and Twitter account. I have deleted both. I can't say sorry enough. It was the lowest thing I had ever done.
我创建了那个账号和推特账号。我已经把它们都删除了。我说多少个对不起都不够。这是我做过的最低劣的事情。
When you included it in your latest Jezebel article, it finally hit me. There is a living, breathing human being who is reading this shit. I'm attacking someone who never harmed me in any way and for no reason whatsoever.
当你把它写进你最新的 Jezebel 文章时，我终于意识到。有一个活生生的人在读这些垃圾。我正在毫无理由地攻击一个从未伤害过我的人。
I'm done being a troll. Again, I apologize. I made a donation in memory to your dad. I wish you the best."
我不当喷子了。再次向你道歉。我以你父亲的名义捐了款。祝你一切顺利。”
They attached a receipt for a $50 donation to Seattle Cancer Care Alliance, where my dad was treated. I guess he found that out in his research, too. It was designated Memorial Paul West. I didn't know what to say. I wrote, "Is this real? If so, thank you."
他们附上了一张 50 美元捐款给西雅图癌症护理联盟的收据，我父亲就是在那里接受治疗的。我想他也从研究中发现了这一点。捐款用途写着“纪念保罗·韦斯特”。我不知道该说什么。我写道：“这是真的吗？如果是，谢谢你。”
The troll wrote back one more time, apologized again, and this time, he gave me his real name. I could have posted it online, which he knew. But I didn't and I'm not going to be saying it here, either.
喷子又回了一次信，再次道歉，这次他告诉了我他的真实姓名。我本可以在网上公开他的名字，他也知道这一点。但我没有，在这里我也不会说。
That was almost 18 months ago. But I still think about it all the time. Because I still get trolled every day. If I could get through to one troll-- the meanest one I ever had-- couldn't I feasibly get through to any of them? All of them? Was he special or did I do something right? I wonder how he would tell me to respond to the people trolling me today. I wish I could ask him. But then I realized, I could.
那已经是近 18 个月前的事了。但我仍然一直想起它。因为我每天还是会被喷。如果我能打动一个喷子——我遇到过最恶劣的那个——那理论上我难道不能打动他们所有人吗？他们所有人？他是特别的吗？还是我做对了什么？我想知道他会建议我如何回应今天喷我的人。我希望能问问他。但后来我意识到，我可以问。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: I don't know. I guess I'm just kind of nervous. But it'll be OK, right?
我不知道。我想我只是有点紧张。但没关系的，对吧？
(SUBJECT) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: Yeah.
是的。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: This is me in a studio with producer Chana Joffe-Walt and a phone.
这是我和制作人查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）在一个演播室里，面前是一部电话。
[DIAL TONE SOUNDS]
[拨号音]
Hello?
喂？
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Hello?
Hello.
喂。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Hi, how are you?
嗨，你好吗？
I got to tell you, I'm really nervous at the moment.
我得告诉你，我现在真的很紧张。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: I'm a little nervous also.
我也有一点紧张。
(SUBJECT) MAN: At least I'm not alone.
至少我不是一个人。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: No. No, not at all.
不。完全不是。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: I asked him why he chose me. He'd said in his email that it wasn't because of the rape joke thing. So what exactly did I do?
我问他为什么选择我。他在邮件里说那不是因为强奸笑话的事。那我到底做了什么？
Well, it revolved around one issue that you write about a lot, which was your being heavy.
嗯，这主要围绕着你经常写的一个议题，那就是关于你的体型。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
The struggles you had regarding being a woman of size, or whatever the term may be.
关于作为一个大码女性的挣扎，或者无论那个术语叫什么。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: You can say fat. That's what I say.
你可以说“胖”。我就是这么说的。
OK. Fat.
好的。胖。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: I write a lot about body image. About the stigma and discrimination that fat people face. About being a fat woman. He told me that, at the time, he was about 75 pounds heavier than he wanted to be. He hated his body. He was miserable. And reading about fat people-- particularly fat women-- accepting and loving themselves as they were infuriated him for reasons he couldn't articulate at the time.
我写了很多关于身体形象的文章。关于胖人所面临的耻辱和歧视。关于作为一个胖女人。他告诉我，当时他比自己想要的体重重了约 75 磅。他讨厌自己的身体。他很痛苦。而阅读关于胖人——特别是胖女人——如何接受并爱自己，让他感到无比愤怒，原因是他当时无法表达清楚。
When you talked about being proud of who you are and where you are and where are you're going, that kind of stoked that anger that I had.
当你谈到为自己的身份、现状以及未来感到自豪时，那种言论助长了我心中的愤怒。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: OK. So you found my writing. You found my writing.
好的。所以你发现了我的文章。你找到了我的文章。
(SUBJECT) MAN: I found your writing.
我找到了你的文章。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: And you did not like it.
然后你很不喜欢它。
Certain aspects of it.
其中的某些方面。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah.
是啊。
You used a lot of all caps.
你用了大量全大写字母。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You're just a very-- you almost have no fear when you write. You know? It's like you stand on the desk and you say, this is-- I'm Lindy West and this is what I believe. And you know, fuck you if you don't agree with me. And I-- even though you don't say those words exactly, I'm like, who is this bitch who thinks she knows everything?
你真的很……你在写作时几乎毫无恐惧。你知道吗？就像你站在桌子上说：“我是林迪·韦斯特，这就是我的信仰。如果你不同意，去你的。”尽管你并没有说出那些具体的词，但我当时想：这个自以为无所不知的婊子是谁？
(HOST) LINDY WEST: I asked him if he felt that way because I'm a woman.
我问他是否是因为我是女人才会有这种感觉。
Oh, definitely. Definitely. Women are being more forthright in their writing. You know, they're not-- there isn't a sense of timidity to when they speak or when they write. They're saying it loud.
哦，绝对是。绝对。女性在写作中变得越来越直率。你知道，她们并没有那种……她们说话或写作时并没有胆怯感。她们很大声地表达出来。
And I think that-- and I think-- for me, as well-- it's threatening at first.
而且我认为——对我来说也是——起初这是一种威胁。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Right. You must know that I-- that's why I do that. Because people don't expect to hear from women like that. And I want other women to see me do that and I want women's voices to get louder.
没错。你一定知道我……我之所以那样做，是因为人们没预料到会听到女性这样说话。我希望其他女性看到我这样做，我希望女性的声音能变得更响亮。
I understand. I understand. Here's the thing. I work with women all day. And I don't have an issue with anyone. I could have told you back then, if someone had said to me, oh you're a misogynist. You hate women.
我明白。我明白。事情是这样的。我整天和女性一起工作。我跟任何人都没有问题。如果有人在那时候对我说：“噢，你是厌女症。你讨厌女人。”我可能会反驳说：“不。我爱我的母亲，我爱我的姐妹。”你知道，我爱过我生命中交往过的女朋友。
And I could say, nah-ah. I love my mom, I love my sisters. You know, I've loved my girlfriends that I've had in my life.
但我不能一方面声称自己对女性没问题，另一方面又上网去侮辱她们。你知道吗？刻意寻找她们去造成情感伤害。
But you can't claim to be OK with women and then you go online and insult them. You know? Seek them out to harm them emotionally.
根据我的经验，如果你称一个喷子为厌女者，他几乎总是会说：“哦，我不讨厌女人。我只是讨厌你说的内容。还有那个女人说的内容。还有那个。还有那个。完全是因为毫不相关的理由。”
(HOST) LINDY WEST: In my experience, if you call a troll a misogynist, he'll almost invariably say, oh, I don't hate women. I just hate what you're saying. And what that other woman is saying. And that woman. And that one. For totally unrelated reasons.
所以，听到他承认确实讨厌女性，至少让我感到满足。他说他不再当喷子了，他真的改变了。他告诉我那段时期——我因为大声疾呼和肥胖而被他喷的时候——是他的人生低谷。
So it was satisfying, at least, to hear him admit that, yeah, he hated women. He says he doesn't troll anymore and that he's really changed. He tells me that period of time-- when he was trolling me for being loud and fat-- was a low point for him.
他讨厌自己的身体。女朋友甩了他。他每天都坐在电脑前做着一份没有成就感的工作。他称之为毫无激情的日子。
He hated his body. His girlfriend dumped him. He spent every day in front of a computer at an unfulfilling job. A passionless life, he called it.
然后他逐渐改变了。他申请了研究生院。他找到了新的恋情。他开始教小孩子。他有了目标。渐渐地，他喷人的兴趣消失了。
And then gradually, he changed. He enrolled in graduate school. He found a new relationship. He started teaching little kids. He had a purpose. Slowly, his interest in trolling dried up.
我们核实了他告诉我们关于他自己的几乎所有事情，除了他是否真的停止了喷人？我无法确认，但我相信他。这感觉是真的。如果这全是骗局，那这骗局也让他付出了 50 美元的慈善捐款。
We verified nearly everything that he told us about himself, except did he really stop trolling? I have no way of knowing, but I believe him. It felt true. And if this was all a con, it's one that cost him a $50 charity donation.
我们谈了两个多小时。我花了很长时间试图让他详细地带我梳理他的过错。真正的身体和心理步骤，以及他是如何向自己证明这一切合理的。我觉得如果我能掌握这些细节——把它们收集起来拿在手里——那么也许我就能开始理解所有那些仍然在喷我的人。
We talked for over two hours. And I spent a lot of time trying to get him to walk me through his transgressions in detail. The actual physical and mental steps and how he justified it all to himself. I felt like if I could just get the specifics-- gather them up and hold them in my hands-- then maybe I could start to understand all the people who are still trolling me.
你是怎么发现我爸爸去世的？你是怎么……
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: How did you even find out that my dad died? How did you--
我用了电脑。我谷歌了你，发现你有一位过世的父亲。我发现他有……你有兄弟姐妹。我忘了总共是不是三个。
I went to my computer. I googled you, found out you had a father who had passed. I found out that he had-- you had siblings. I forget if it was three total.
我有两个兄弟姐妹。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: I have two siblings.
所以……
So--
你读了他的讣告吗？
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Did you read his obituary?
我想我读了。我知道他是个音乐家。
I believe I did. I knew he was a musician.
是的。那是我写的。我写的讣告。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah. I wrote that. I wrote his obituary.
我做的是：我用你父亲的名字创建了一个虚假的 Gmail 账号。用他的名字创建了一个虚假的推特账号。简介大意是……嗯，抱歉，我忘了那个名字……名字部分。
What I did was this. I created a fake Gmail account using your father's name. Created a fake Twitter account using his name. The biography was something to the effect of, my name is-- um, sorry, I forget the name-- the first name.
他叫保罗·韦斯特。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: His name was Paul West.
上面写着——我写道：“我叫保罗·韦斯特。我有三个孩子。两个很棒，一个是个白痴。”
It said-- I wrote, my name is Paul West. I've got three kids. Two of them are great and one of them is an idiot.
是啊，你说的是“一个白痴的尴尬父亲”。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah, you said, "embarrassed father of an idiot."
好的。
OK.
“不过另外两个孩子还不错。”然后……
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: "Other two kids are fine, though." And then--
这简直太糟糕了。
That's much more worse.
而且你放了他的照片。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: And you got a picture of him.
我确实放了他的照片。
I did get a picture of him.
你有……你还记得关于他的任何事情吗？你是否……你对他作为一个人有什么感觉吗？
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Did you-- do you remember anything about him? Did he-- did you get a sense of him as a human being?
我读了讣告，我知道他是一个爱孩子的父亲？
I read the obit and I knew he was a dad that loved his kids?
那让你感觉如何？
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: How did that make you feel?
不太好。我的意思是，我几乎立刻就感觉糟透了。你发推文说：“社会今天干得好。”或者类似的话。
Not good. I mean, I felt horrible almost immediately afterwards. You tweeted something along the lines of, good job today, society. Or something along those lines.
是啊。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah.
这只是……这是第一次，它无法从我脑海中挥去。通常，我会发布所有这些网络仇恨，而且往往我会直接忘记。但这个无法离开我。它无法离开我。
It just wouldn't-- for the first time, it wouldn't leave my mind. Usually, I would put out all this internet hate and oftentimes I would just forget about it. This one would not leave me. It would not leave me.
我开始想到你，因为我知道你读过了。我在想，她会怎么感觉？第二天，我给你写了信。
I started thinking about you because I know you had read it. And I'm thinking, how would she feel? And the next day, I wrote you.
是啊。嗯，我……
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah. Well, I--
我真的很抱歉。
(SUBJECT) MAN: And I truly am sorry about that.
是啊，我的意思是……你失去过什么人吗？你能想象吗？你能想象吗？
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Yeah, I mean-- have you lost anyone? Can you imagine? Can you imagine?
我不能。我不能。我不知道还能说什么，只能说我很抱歉。
I can't. I can't. I don't know what else to say except that I'm sorry.
嗯，你知道，我整天都在受到辱骂，每一天。这是我工作的一部分。这是任何人对我做过的最刻薄的事情。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Well, you know, I get abuse all day, everyday. It's part of my job. And this was the meanest thing anyone's ever done to me.
哦。
Oh.
我的意思是，绝对……我的意思是，那真的很痛苦。他刚去世。但你也是……你是我遇到过的唯一一个道歉的喷子。不仅仅是对我。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: I mean, abso-- I mean, it was really fresh. He had just died. But you're also-- you're the only troll who has ever apologized. Not just to me.
我以前从没听说过这种事。我的意思是，我不认识任何曾经……曾经得到过道歉的人。我只是……我的意思是，你知道，谢谢你。我……
I've never heard of this happening before. I mean, I don't know anyone who's ever-- who's ever gotten an apology. And I just-- I mean, you know, thank you. I--
我很高兴你获得了一些安慰。
I'm glad that you have some solace.
老实说，我确实得到了一些安慰。我原谅了他。我为他感到难过。很难相信有人真的会改变。但他做到了。我在其中找到了巨大的安慰。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: Honestly, I did have some solace. I forgave him. I felt sorry for him. It's so difficult to believe that anyone ever really changes. And he did it. I found immense comfort in that.
谈话接近尾声时，我记得他在邮件中承认，他曾用多个喷子账号骚扰我，不仅仅是“PawWestDonezo”。
Toward the end of our conversation, I remembered that, in his email, he confessed that he'd harassed me from multiple troll accounts, not just PawWestDonezo.
我有回过信吗？有什么我不知道的吗？他说有。有一次，他用个人账号发了些刻薄的东西，我把它转发给了我所有的 4 万名粉丝。他感到非常羞愧。
Did I ever write back? Was there anything I didn't know? He said, yeah. One time, he'd sent something mean from his personal account and I retweeted it to all my 40,000 followers. He was mortified.
我试着回忆那是关于什么的。我想你提到了一个喜剧演员。你发推特提过一个威胁要把女朋友从楼梯上推下去的喜剧演员。
And I'm trying to remember what it was about. I think you had mentioned a comedian. You had tweeted about a comedian who had threatened to throw his girlfriend down the stairs.
噢，不。他说他希望我会从楼梯上摔下来。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Oh, no. He said he wished that I would fall down a flight of stairs.
哦，好的。我想我说的是，比如……我不知道我是转发了它，还是……我说了什么？
Oh, OK. And I think I said, like-- I don't know if I retweeted it or I-- what did I say?
噢。噢，天哪。我记得你。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Oh. Oh, my god. I remember you.
好的。
OK.
噢，天哪。你说了一些类似“我希望我是那个把她推下去的人”之类的话。或者……
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Oh, my god. You said something like, I wish I could be the one to push her or something. Or--
或者我想是“真可惜林迪不是你的女朋友”。
(SUBJECT) MAN: Or I thought it was, too bad Lindy isn't your girlfriend.
噢，是，是，是，是，是。噢，天哪。我记得你。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, my god. I remember you.
是啊。那是我。我是个混蛋。
Yeah. That's me. I'm a dick.
[林迪大笑]
[LINDY LAUGHS]
我无法相信……我的意思是，我……有这么多喷子。我无法相信……我无法相信我记得你。
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: I can't believe-- I mean, I-- there's so many trolls. I can't believe-- I can't believe I remember you.
是的，那是我。
Yeah, that was me.
此时，一直在听的我的制作人查娜，忍不住插话了。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: At this point, my producer Chana, who'd been listening, couldn't stop herself from jumping in.
天哪，听你们俩说话，听起来就像是：“哦，你也去那所高中？我也去那所高中？”天哪！
(SUBJECT) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: God, hearing you guys, you sound like you're like, oh, you went to that high school? I went to that high school, too? Holy cow!
是啊。
Yeah.
嗯，你知道，我的意思是，这现在是我生活中非常正常化的一部分。我的意思是，老实说……和一个真正明白我在说什么的人交谈是一种解脱，尽管他从另一个方向切入。你知道，几乎没有人理解……
(INTERVIEWER) LINDY WEST: Well, you know, I mean it's such a normalized part of my life now. I mean, honestly-- and it's kind of a relief to talk to someone who really knows what I'm talking about, even though he's coming at it from the other direction. You know, there's almost no one who understands--
嗯，你知道吗？作为一名前喷子，在现在之前，我从未告诉过任何活人我做过这种事。所以从某种角度来说，把这些从我胸口卸下感觉真好。把我秘密的生活——我旧的生活——我不知道。把这些恶魔驱赶出去感觉真好。
Well, you know what? As a former troll, I never told a single living human being until now that I did this. So it's good, in a way, to get that off my chest. To get my secret life-- my old life-- I don't know. It just feels good to kind of exorcise these demons.
和我的喷子交谈感觉非常容易，甚至很舒服。我喜欢他，我不知道该怎么处理这种感觉。发现他竟然如此正常，这很令人恐惧。他有喜欢他的女同事。他有一个爱他的真实女友。她们根本不知道他曾经为了找乐子而上网去折磨女性。
(HOST) LINDY WEST: It felt really easy-- comfortable, even-- to talk to my troll. I liked him and I didn't know what to do with that. It's frightening to discover that he's so normal. He has female co-workers who enjoy his company. He has a real live girlfriend who loves him. They have no idea that he used to go online and traumatize women for fun.
喷子活在我们中间。我收到过匿名评论，说他们曾在电影院见过我，说我是个婊子；或者说他们曾在餐馆服务过我，说我的胸部没有照片上看起来那么大。人们说互联网上发生了什么并不重要——那不是真实生活。但多亏了网络喷子，我永远被提醒：文明世界与我们最丑陋的自我之间的界限只是一个幻觉。
Trolls live among us. I've gotten anonymous comments from people saying they met me at a movie theater and I was a bitch or they served me at a restaurant and my boobs aren't as big as they look in pictures. People say it doesn't matter what happens on the internet-- that it's not real life. But thanks to internet trolls, I'm perpetually reminded that the boundary between the civilized world and our worst selves is just an illusion.
喷子们每天仍在浪费我的时间并消耗我的精神健康。但老实说，我不希望他们遭受任何痛苦。他们的痛苦正是导致我们走到这一步的根源。这就是我从我的喷子身上学到的。
Trolls still waste my time and tax my mental health on a daily basis. But honestly, I don't wish them any pain. Their pain is what got us here in the first place. That's what I learned from my troll.
如果他说的是真的——他只是需要在生活中找到某种意义——那么对于那些仍然在这么做的人来说，这是一个多么令人心碎的诊断啊。我无法给数以百万计的匿名陌生人带来目标和满足感。但我可以记住，不要像他们无视我的人性那样，去无视他们的人性。
If what he said is true-- that he just needed to find some meaning in his life-- then what a heartbreaking diagnosis for all the people who are still at it. I can't give purpose and fulfillment to millions of anonymous strangers. But I can remember not to lose sight of their humanity the way that they lost sight of mine.
人是可以触及的。我有证据。同理心、勇气、善良——这些是我从父亲那里学到的，尽管他从未知道我会有多么需要它们。又或者，他知道。
Humans can be reached. I have proof. Empathy, boldness, kindness-- those are things I learned from my dad, though he never knew how much I'd need them. Or maybe he did.
他是一位爵士乐手，我出生时他为我写了一首歌。现在听起来，感觉他就是为这一刻而写的。我把最后的话留给他。
He was a jazz musician and when I was born he wrote a song about me. And listening to it now, it feels like he wrote it for just this moment. I'll give the last word to him.
你胆子很大，小姑娘。满怀胆量，小姑娘。在这充满怀疑和琐碎理性的季节来到这里。在这个你不配得到的世界。你胆子很大，小姑娘。
You got a lot of nerve, little girl. Bundles of nerve, little girl. To come here in a season full of doubt and tattered reason. In a world you don't deserve. You got a lot of nerve, little girl.
西雅图的林迪·韦斯特。自从我们一年前第一次播出林迪的故事以来，发生了一件有趣的事。她的故事在推特内部引发了一场讨论，导致其当时的首席执行官迪克·科斯特罗（Dick Costolo）给员工写了一份备忘录，后来泄露给了公众。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Lindy West in Seattle. So since we first ran Lindy's story a year ago, something interesting happened. Her story spurred a discussion inside Twitter that led its CEO at the time, Dick Costolo, to write a memo to employees that was leaked to the public.
备忘录写道：“我们在处理滥用行为和喷子方面做得一团糟。而且我们已经搞砸多年了。这不是什么秘密。世界其他地方每天都在谈论它。
It said, quote, "We suck at dealing with abuse and trolls. And we've sucked at it for years. It's no secret. And the rest of the world talks about it every day.
坦率地说，我对我们处理这个问题的方式感到羞耻。这太荒谬了。这毫无借口。”此后的几个月里，推特推出了一些新的反霸凌工具和政策。它们的评价毁誉参半，比如“做得还不够”。
I'm frankly ashamed of how poorly we've dealt with this issue. It's absurd. There's no excuse for it." In the months since then, Twitter has introduced some new anti-bullying tools and policies. They've gotten decidedly mixed reviews, like "not far enough."
好吧，好吧，好吧，小姑娘。
Well, well, well, little girl.
第二幕，“自由薯条”。所以，我们从听众那里收到的评论通常远没有林迪·韦斯特每天受到的那么恶毒。但有一段时间，我们节目组的女性成员一直收到像下面这样的邮件。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act two, "Freedom Fries." So the comments that we get from our listeners are usually nowhere as vicious as what Lindy West gets on a daily basis. But for a while now, the women on our staff have been getting emails like this one.
引用：“查娜·乔菲-沃尔特的声音简直让人难以忍受，凡是有她参与的剧集，我都会关掉。简单搜索了一下发现了一个恰当的描述，就是‘人声炸裂音’（vocal fry）。《美国生活》怎么能把这种声音放在节目里？我实在想不通。”
Quote, "The voice of Chana Joffe-Walt is just too much to bear and I turn off any episode she's on. A quick bit of research found an appropriate description, which is vocal fry. How can This American Life have this on the show? It escapes me."
“人声炸裂音”在过去一年里在公共广播中得到了一些报道，但如果你不知道这是什么意思，听听查娜的一段录音。
Vocal fry has gotten a bit of coverage on Public Radio in the last year, but if you have no idea what this is talking about, here's a clip of Chana.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特：而且汤普森一直在听那个术语——学校到监狱的管道。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: And Thompson kept hearing that term-- school to prison pipeline.
好的。听到她声音在“管道”（pipeline）这个词上那种吱吱作响的方式了吗？那就是“人声炸裂音”。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: OK. Hear the way that her voice kind of creaks on the word pipeline? That's vocal fry.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特：管道。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: Pipeline.
但这不仅仅是查娜。一位男士在 11 月写信给我们，引用：“人声炸裂音是年轻美国女性中一种日益增长的时尚。米基·米克（Miki Meek）提供了一个这种不幸癖好的生动而刺耳的例子。”顺便说一下，米基听起来是这样的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: But it's not just Chana. A man wrote us in November, quote, "Vocal fry is a growing fad among young American women. Miki Meek provides a vivid and grating example of this unfortunate affectation." Miki, by the way, sounds like this.
米基·米克：她从未经历过教堂之外的任何事情。基本上她就离开了威尔和孩子们。
(HOST) MIKI MEEK: She'd never experienced anything outside the church. And she basically checked out on Will and the kids.
有人写信给我们提到艾利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel），她曾多次上过我们的节目。现在是 NPR 科学节目《Invisibilia》的联合主持人。引用：“也许艾利克斯可以报道一下‘人声炸裂音’流行病。听听她的见解会很有趣，因为她显然自己也是受害者。”作为记录，下面是艾利克斯的声音。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Somebody wrote us about Alix Spiegel, who's been on our show many, many times. Now co-hosts the NPR science program Invisibilia . Quote, "Perhaps Alix could cover the vocal fry epidemic. It'd be really interesting to hear her take, as she is clearly a victim herself." For the record, here is Alix.
艾利克斯·斯皮格尔：因为罗克珊是唯一一个抚养年幼女儿的人，她必须能够工作。
(HOST) ALIX SPIEGEL: Because Roxanne was the only one supporting her young daughter, she had to be able to work.
艾尔娜·贝克、玛丽·贝丝·克什纳、斯塔莉·基恩、尤伟·肖。当调查记者苏珊·扎尔金德（Susan Zalkind）去年在我们的节目中讲述联邦调查局射杀一名与波士顿马拉松爆炸案有关的男子的故事时，她听起来是这样的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Elna Baker, Mary Beth Kerschner, Starlee Kine, Yowei Shaw. When investigative reporter Susan Zalkind was on our show last year with the story of the FBI shooting a man connected to the Boston Marathon bombers, she sounded like this.
苏珊·扎尔金德：但易卜拉欣也因为在佛罗里达州商场的停车位殴打一名男子致昏迷而被捕。
(HOST) SUSAN ZALKIND: But Ibrahim also got arrested for beating a guy unconscious over a parking space at a mall in Florida.
一位女士写信来，引用：“那女人声音里的那种低吼声太烦人了，我把它关掉了。”一位男士写道，引用：“听着，我知道有雇佣女性的压力——特别是刚毕业的年轻女性。而且，她们更有可能以较低的工资工作。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: A woman wrote in, quote, "The growl in the woman's voice was so annoying that I turned it off." A man wrote, quote, "Listen, I know there's pressure to hire females-- in particular, young females just out of college. And besides, they're likely to work for less money.
但你们非得选择英语世界里最令人恼火的声音吗？我的意思是，你们是被迫的吗？或者也许，正如我所猜测的那样，NPR 举办了寻找这种声音的全国性比赛。”
But do you have to choose the most irritating voices in the English speaking world? I mean, are you forced to? Or maybe, as I imagine, NPR runs national contests looking for them."
“人声炸裂音”这个词在 2011 年开始被广泛使用，此前一项针对长岛大学 34 名大学生的研究发现，其中三分之二的人有这种发音，通常出现在句子的结尾。一位记者在《科学》杂志的网站上撰写了关于该研究的报道。Gawker、赫芬顿邮报、Boing Boing 等网站进行了转载。几天之内，它就成为了《科学》杂志网站 15 年来最受欢迎的文章。其他媒体也纷纷跟进。
The term vocal fry started to get wide usage in 2011 after a study of 34 college students at Long Island University found that 2/3 of them had it, usually at the ends of sentences. A reporter wrote a story about that study at the website of Science Magazine . Gawker , Huffington Post , Boing Boing , and other sites linked to it. And within days, it became the most popular article ever published on the Science Magazine website and its 15 years. Other media glommed on.
一种被称为“人声炸裂音”的东西正在潜入年轻女性的说话模式中。NBC 首席医学编辑南希·斯奈德曼（Nancy Snyderman）博士来解释一下。
Something called vocal fry that is creeping into the speech patterns of young women. NBC's chief medical editor, Dr. Nancy Snyderman, is here to explain.
这段《今日秀》的故事提出了这种说话方式会损害年轻女性嗓音的可能性。自那时起，许多研究人员表示这似乎并非事实。《今日秀》的报道还称这只会影响女性。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This story on The Today Show raises the possibility that talking this way harms young women's voices. Since then, many researchers have said this doesn't seem to be true. The Today Show story also says this only affects women.
男性有类似的情况吗？
Is there anything equivalent in men?
南希·斯奈德曼博士：没有。你知道有趣的是……
(SUBJECT) DR. NANCY SNYDERMAN: No, there isn't. And you know whats interesting--
现在有强有力的证据表明男性也会这样。而且像许多其他报道一样，《今日秀》的故事将“人声炸裂音”病态化了——说它是某种问题，而不是有些人说话的方式。它教观众去识别它。《今日秀》主持人马特·劳尔（Matt Lauer）在节目开头说他从没听说过这个，在节目结束时却说他以前从未注意到它，现在他要提高警惕了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: There's now robust evidence that men do this, too. And like a lot of the other coverage, The Today Show story pathologizes vocal fry-- says that it's some kind of problem instead of just the way that some people talk. And it teaches viewers to spot it. Today Show host Matt Lauer starts a segment saying that he's never heard of this and ends it saying he'd never noticed it before and now he's going to be on the alert for it.
南希·斯奈德曼博士：就是这样。它很深沉。
(SUBJECT) DR. NANCY SNYDERMAN: That's it. It's that deep.
新闻主播：好吧，这是我第一次真正听到，就在金·卡戴珊的录音里。
(SUBJECT) NEWSCASTER: Well, that's the first time I actually heard it, in Kim Kardashian there.
南希·斯奈德曼博士：金·卡戴珊真的有这种声音。
(SUBJECT) DR. NANCY SNYDERMAN: Kim Kardashian really has it.
我会开始留意……
I will start to listen--
南希·斯奈德曼博士：你只是不够时髦，进不去那个圈子。
(SUBJECT) DR. NANCY SNYDERMAN: You're just not going to be hip enough to be there.
新闻主播：我会更仔细听的。
(SUBJECT) NEWSCASTER: I'll listen more carefully.
《今日秀》的故事和其他报道将“人声炸裂音”视为一种新现象——正在上升、一种时尚、一种流行病。但正如宾夕法尼亚大学的语言学家马克·利伯曼（Mark Lieberman）指出的那样，目前没有任何证据支持或反对这一点。没有证据表明它现在比以往任何时候都更普遍。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: The Today Show story and other stories treat vocal fry as if it's a new phenomenon-- on the rise, a fad, an epidemic. But as a linguist at the University of Pennsylvania, Mark Lieberman, has pointed out, there is still no evidence of that-- pro or con. No evidence that it is more common now than it's always been.
在我们广播节目收到的关于“人声炸裂音”的几十封邮件中，令人震惊的是人们的激烈程度。这些是我们收到的最愤怒的邮件。他们称这些女性的声音不可忍受、痛苦、令人恼火的幼稚、极其烦人、让人无法集中注意力。严重到引起不适。
What's striking in the dozens of emails about vocal fry that we've gotten here at our radio show is how vehement people are. These are some of the angriest emails we ever get. They call these women's voices unbearable, excruciating, annoyingly adolescent, beyond annoying, difficult to pay attention. So severe as to cause discomfort.
忍受不了这种痛苦，让人分心地恶心。无法克服我被激怒的感觉。我非常震惊。损害了记者的可信度。贬低了报道的价值。这是一种选择——非常不专业。
Can't stand the pain, distractingly disgusting. Could not get over how annoyed I was. I am so appalled. Detracts from the credibility of the journalist. Degrades the value of the reportage. It's a choice-- very unprofessional.
斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）：最近，每次我和其他女性广播制作人聚在一起，就像在比拼战争故事。
(HOST) STEPHANIE FOO: Lately, every time I get together with female radio producers, it's just like comparing war stories.
这是斯蒂芬妮·富，我们节目组较年轻的制作人之一。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: That's Stephanie Foo, one of the younger producers here on our show.
就像列清单一样，哦，这周有人说我这个……关于我的声音。有人说我听起来像个吸了毒的 13 岁孩子。有人说我的声音听起来像在碎石路上开车。有人说听到我的声音他们想自杀。
(HOST) STEPHANIE FOO: It's just listing off, oh, somebody said this about me-- my voice-- this week. Somebody said I sound like a stoner 13-year-old. Somebody said that my voice sounds like driving on gravel. Somebody said they wanted to kill themselves hearing my voice.
听众一直抱怨我们节目里的年轻女性报道。他们过去抱怨记者使用“就像”（like）这个词，以及抱怨“上扬语调”（upspeak），也就是在句子结尾用问号，然后像这样说话？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Listeners have always complained about young women reporting on our show. They used to complain about reporters using the word like and about upspeak, which is when you put a question mark at the end of a sentence and talk like this?
但我们已经很少收到那样的邮件了。那些不喜欢听年轻女性在广播中说话的人已经转向了“人声炸裂音”。
But we don't get many emails like that anymore. People who don't like listening to young women on the radio have moved on to vocal fry.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特：我只是觉得，我的声音？真的吗？像……
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: I just feel like, my voice? Really? Like--
这是制作人查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。记得吧，我读过一位听众的信，他发现她的声音“难以忍受”。查娜说如果有人对她的报道、写作或采访有意见，她都没问题。但她的声音？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This is producer Chana Joffe-Walt. Remember, I read a letter from a listener who found her voice "too much to bear." Chana says that it's fine with her if somebody has a problem with her reporting or her writing or her interviewing. But her voice?
我只是在尝试说话。真的，从我嘴里发出的声音方式让你烦恼？我该对此做什么呢？即使是现在，当我们谈论它时，我也注意到了我每一次发出这种声音。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: I'm just trying to speak. Like literally, the way that the voice comes out of my mouth bothers you? What am I supposed to do about that? And like, even now, as we're speaking about it, I am noticing every single time I do it.
然后我会因为每一次发出这种声音而讨厌自己，并试图不这样做。但试图不这样做是不可能的，因为这就是我说话的方式。因为这是我真正的声音。这真让人发疯。
And then hating every single time I do it and trying not to do it. But trying not to do it is impossible because it's the way that I talk. Because it's my actual voice. It's crazy-making.
有趣的是。在我们开始为这个故事讨论它之前，我甚至从来没注意到你声音里的这种特征。然后……
(HOST) IRA GLASS: It's funny. Until we started talking about it for this story, I never even noticed it in your voice. And then--
而现在你每秒都能注意到了。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: And now you notice it every second.
是啊。你注意到我也有吗？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Yeah. Have you noticed that I do it, too?
直到现在才注意到。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: Not until right now.
是啊。是啊。即使当我说这些话的时候。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Yeah. Yeah. Even as I say these words.
当其他女性这样做时，我也没有注意到，直到我开始阅读关于“人声炸裂音”现象的内容。然后我就注意到了。现在当别人这样做时，我会觉得很烦。我的意思是，我不会一直注意到它，但如果我在思考它并听到其他人——特别是其他女性——这样做时，我就变成了一个厌女的女人。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: And I didn't notice it when other women do it, either, until I started to read about the phenomenon of vocal fry. And then I did notice it. And I find it annoying now when other people do it. I mean, I don't notice it all the time, but if I am thinking about it and hear other people do it-- other women do it, especially-- I become a woman who hates women.
哇。你就像……就像你吸收了压迫者的信息。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Wow. You're like-- it's like you've absorbed the messages of your oppressor.
我现在在你声音里也听到了。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: I hear it in you now.
是啊。我因为节目的很多事情而受到批评。从来没有人指出过这一点。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Yeah. I get criticized for a lot of things in the emails to the show. No one has ever pointed this out.
这完全不出所料。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: That's completely unsurprising.
你不觉得这只是性别歧视吗？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Don't you think it's just sexism?
是的。我认为它触及了人们内心深处的一部分，在那里他们不想听到年轻女性说话——包括我。就像，这在我内心也引发了这种感觉。
(HOST) CHANA JOFFE-WALT: Yes. I think it taps into some deep part of people's selves where they don't want to hear young women-- including me. Like, it taps into that in me.
几年前，斯坦福大学的一位语言学家彭妮·埃克特（Penny Eckert）在 NPR 听到一位年轻女性，很惊讶地听到有人用如此随意的风格，带着这么多“人声炸裂音”来播报严肃的新闻。她想，嗯，她不应该在 NPR 工作。她听起来没有权威性。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: A few years ago, a linguist named Penny Eckert from Stanford University heard a young woman at NPR and was surprised to hear somebody speaking in such a casual style with so much vocal fry about serious news. And she thought, well, she shouldn't be on NPR. She doesn't sound authoritative.
彭妮·埃克特：当我把它放给我的学生听，问他们觉得她听起来怎么样时，他们说她听起来很棒。他们觉得她听起来很有权威感。那时候我就知道我落后于时代了。
(SUBJECT) PENNY ECKERT: When I played it for my students and asked them how they thought she sounded, they said she sounded great. And they thought she sounded authoritative. Then I knew that I was behind the curve.
所以她做了一个小研究——一项初步研究。她给 584 个人播放了 Marketplace 记者萨莉·赫希普斯（Sally Herships）的片段。她请他们评价这位记者听起来有多大的权威感。结果是——40 岁以下的人听到的感受与 40 岁以上的人非常不同。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: So she did a little study-- a preliminary study. She played clips of a Marketplace reporter named Sally Herships for 584 people. And she asked them to rate how authoritative the reporter sounded. The results-- people under 40 heard it very differently than people over 40.
彭妮·埃克特：年轻人觉得那非常有权威感，而老年人则不觉得。
(SUBJECT) PENNY ECKERT: The younger people found that quite authoritative and the older people did not.
所以，如果人们对电台里的这些记者有意见，那意味着他们老了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: So if people are having a problem with these reporters on the radio, what it means is they're old.
是的。我认为老年人无论如何往往会对这类事情变得脾气暴躁。但是……媒体对此完全疯狂了。我的意思是，我不断接到媒体的请求。
(SUBJECT) PENNY ECKERT: Yeah. I think old people tend to get cranky about this stuff, anyway. But-- but the media are just all over it. I mean, I'm constantly getting requests from media.
他们想谈论年轻女性说话时的那种疯狂方式。他们做的第一件事就是把它归咎于年轻女性，尽管年轻男性也在做同样的事情。所以这就是为什么——这是对年轻人的监管，但我认为，尤其是针对年轻女性。
And they want to talk about the crazy ways that young women are speaking. And the first thing they do is attribute it to young women, even though young men are doing it, too. So that's why-- it's a policing of young people, but I think, most particularly, young women.
她说同样的事情发生在“上扬语调”和“就像”这个词上。记者会给她打电话谈论这些事情。他们把这些指为年轻女性的问题，而年轻男性也都有这些行为。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: She says the same thing happened with upspeak and with the word like. Reporters would call her about these things. They'd point to them as a problem with young women, when young men do all that also.
她说人们对这些事情大惊小怪，但这就是生活的一部分。随着年龄增长，我们与年轻人的说话方式会脱节。她给每个人的建议，包括她自己？适应它。
She says people get worked up about this stuff, but it's just part of life. As we age, we fall out of touch with how younger people speak. Her advice to everybody, including herself? Get over it.
接下来。你知道人们在互联网上真正喜欢什么吗？小动物。那为什么他们会因为这个而互相大喊大叫呢？这在一分钟后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
Coming up. You know what people really love on the internet? Little baby animals. So why would they be yelling at each other about that? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目……你现在是在听我声音里的“人声炸裂音”，而不是我在说的具体内容吗？
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- and are you only listening to the vocal fry in my voice right now and not the actual words that I'm saying?
今天的节目——“如果你没有什么好话可说，请用全大写字母说出来。”这个故事是关于网络评论者的。我们进入了节目的第三幕。
Today's show-- "If You Don't Have Anything Nice to Say, Say It in All Caps." This story's about internet commenters. We've arrived at act three of our program.
第三幕，“猎物之词”。所以每隔几个月，似乎总有一些研究发布，声称互联网上大约 15% 的内容就是猫——猫视频、猫照片。又或者可能是 1% 是猫，或者可能是其他看起来非常疯狂的数字。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act three, "Words of Prey." So every few months, it seems there's some study that gets released saying that something like 15% of the internet is just cats-- cat videos, cat pictures. Or maybe it's 1% is cats or maybe it's some other number that really just seems crazy.
我的重点是互联网喜欢动物。考虑到这一点，下面请听乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）讲述我们一年前首次播出的这个故事。
My point is the internet loves animals. With that in mind, here's Jonathan Menjivar with this story that we first broadcast a year ago.
在野生动物摄像头世界里，伍兹霍尔鱼鹰摄像头（Woods Hole Osprey cam）只是一个小角色。它当然不是熊猫摄像头。地球上到处都有针对野牛、企鹅的摄像头——我刚刚看了一个水母的，如果你想在办公桌前感觉像嗑了药一样，这很有用。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: In the world of wildlife animal cams, the Woods Hole Osprey cam is a bit player. It's certainly no Panda Cam. All over the Earth, there are web cams trained on bison, penguins-- I just watched a jellyfish one that's useful if you want to feel stoned at your desk.
但直到去年夏天之前，伍兹霍尔海洋研究所（WHOI）的鱼鹰摄像头——大多数人简称为 WHOI——他们的摄像头没有多少流量。摄像头是大约十年前作为一名在 WHOI 工作的女性的某种爱好项目启动的。她在 2009 年去世了。
But until last summer, the Osprey Cam at the Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution-- most people just call it WHOI-- their camera didn't get much traffic. The cam was started about a decade ago as a kind of pet project of a woman who worked at WHOI. She died in 2009.
杰弗里·布罗德（Jeffrey Brodeur）：她的名字叫谢丽，她深度参与了鱼鹰项目。热爱动物。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Her name was Sherri and she was deeply involved in the Osprey. Loved animals.
这是杰弗里·布罗德。他在 WHOI 工作。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: This is Jeffrey Brodeur. He works at WHOI.
杰弗里·布罗德：事实上，我们以她的名字命名了一只鱼鹰，最糟糕的事情之一就是那只被我们命名的鸟被车撞了。那只鸟死了，然后那个冬天，她也去世了。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And in fact, we named one of the osprey after her, which-- one of the worst parts was that the bird we named got hit by a car. The bird died and then, that winter, she died.
谢丽只有 41 岁。她去世后，杰弗里接管了摄像头的责任。三年内，没有任何鸟出现。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Sherri was only 41. After her death, Jeffrey took over responsibility for the camera. And for three years, no bird showed up.
杰弗里·布罗德：在那一段时间里，这个巢穴上笼罩着一种空虚的苍白，一季又一季，我们什么都没有。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Kind of this empty pallor hung over this nest for a while, where season after season, we didn't have anything.
有一年，一只雄鸟和一只雌鸟出现了。但它们没有繁殖。它们一年后回来了。2014 年 4 月 19 日下午 3 点，第一个蛋出现了。至少，根据留言板上的一份记录是这样。互联网上围绕巢穴的兴奋感增长了。然后第二个蛋出现了，接着是第三个。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: One year, a male and female showed up. But they didn't breed. They returned a year later. And on April 19, 2014, at 3 o'clock in the afternoon, the first egg arrived. At least, that's according to one account on a message board. Excitement around the nest grew on the internet. Then a second egg arrived, and then a third.
杰弗里·布罗德：对。这太神奇了。所以人们真的开始坐起来并关注伍兹霍尔鱼鹰巢回来了。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Right. Which is amazing. So people were really starting to kind of sit up and pay attention that the Woods Hole Osprey Nest is back.
“羽毛头”——显然这就是一些鱼鹰成瘾者对自己的称呼。他们开始把视频放上 YouTube，并发布巢穴中发生的一切的实况转播。凌晨 5:44——“第四个视频开始两分钟，看起来很像正常的喂食。”凌晨 5:45——“三只全都聚在一起，我觉得至少有两只在被喂食。我也觉得左边那只现在得到的没有之前喂得多的那只多。”凌晨 5:46——“成鸟停顿了一下，看了看四周。”
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Featherheads-- that's apparently what some osprey addicts call themselves. They started putting videos on YouTube and posting play-by-play action of everything that was happening in the nest. 5:44 AM-- "Two minutes into fourth video and it's looking very much like a normal feeding." 5:45 AM-- "All three are clustered around and I think at least two are being fed. I also think the one on the left isn't getting as much now as the one that was fed more earlier." 5:46 AM-- "Adult paused for a second and looked around."
在留言板上，人们开始发布他们看到的截图——幼鸟什么时候进食，什么时候排便。所以所有的目光都盯着巢穴。人们很兴奋。然后——
On the message boards, people started posting screenshots of things they were seeing-- when the nestlings ate, when they pooped. So all these eyes were on the nest. People were excited. And then--
杰弗里·布罗德：人们几乎立刻注意到这个巢穴里的情况不太正常。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: It was almost immediate that people started noticing that things were not quite normal in this nest.
母亲——她会把鱼带到巢穴，但她似乎在囤积它们，而不是与幼鸟分享。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: The mom-- she'd bring fish to the nest, but she seemed to be hoarding them, not sharing with the nestlings.
杰弗里·布罗德：然后他们开始询问关于母亲的情况。母亲表现出什么样的行为？她似乎喂食不多。她似乎没有与幼崽互动。当她开始攻击幼崽时，情况彻底爆发了。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And then they're starting to ask about the mother. And what kind of behavior is the mother displaying? She seems not to be feeding as much. And she's kind of not interacting with the babies. And then it all blew up when she started attacking the young.
我从某人那里听说她“撕碎了幼崽”。她在啄——啄它们的头。她在使用爪子，某种程度上……想象一下就像直升机一样。她盘旋在这三只幼崽身上，它们低下头，缩紧脖子保护自己，而她就开始又抓又啄——对着眼睛攻击。
I heard from someone that she was, quote, unquote, "ripping apart the young." She was pecking-- pecking at their heads. She was using her talons, kind of-- imagine almost like a helicopter. She's hovered over these three young, who are putting their heads down, tucking their necks down to protect themselves from her as she just starts clawing away and pecking at them-- going for the eyes.
现在，如果这发生在森林里，那就是大自然常态的一天。但这不是发生在森林里。这是发生在互联网上。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Now, if this happened in a forest, it's just another day for nature. But it wasn't happening in a forest. It was happening on the internet.
杰弗里·布罗德：从那时起，她就被叫作“妈妈斯拉”（Momzilla）。这是他们给她的名字。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And from that point on, it was Momzilla. That was the name they gave her.
我看过这些视频，它们很难接受。这不是狮子捕杀羚羊，因为它饿了。这是一位母亲在攻击她的孩子，看起来毫无理由。不仅仅是攻击它们——还在饿着它们。当爸爸把鱼带到巢穴时，母亲往往在给幼鸟任何东西之前就吃掉了大部分鱼。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: I've watched the videos and they are hard to take. It's not a lion taking down a gazelle because he's hungry. This is a mother attacking her kids, seemingly for no reason. And not just attacking them-- starving them. When the dad brings fish to the nest, the mother often eats most of the fish before she offers the nestlings anything.
夏天结束时，一个已经沉寂多年的摄像头留言板突然有了数百页的帖子。美国至少有 40 个鱼鹰摄像头。现在，杰弗里坐在了“鱼鹰摄像头里的《比弗利娇妻》”上了。伍兹霍尔有了每个人都想看的火车失事现场。
By the end of the summer, a message board devoted to the cam that had been quiet for years suddenly had hundreds of pages of posts. There are at least 40 osprey cams around the US. And now, Jeffrey was sitting on the Real Housewives of osprey cams. Woods Hole had the train wreck that everyone wanted to watch.
留言板上的人显然对鱼鹰了解很多，但他们无法克制自己将人类动机附着在母亲的行为上。有人写道：“注意她有时看着它们的方式，几乎就像在挑衅它们动一下。”
People on the message boards clearly knew a ton about osprey, but they couldn't help themselves from attaching human motives to the mother's actions. One person wrote, "Note how she looks at them at times, almost like daring them to move."
杰弗里·布罗德：这是七月晚些时候的一条。“求求你们。我刚看了一个 YouTube 视频，显示这只鱼鹰妈妈在攻击她所有的宝宝，其中一只非常凶狠。这不正常。我见过正常的鱼鹰妈妈是充满爱心并为宝宝担忧的。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: So here's one from a little bit later in July. "Please. I just watched a YouTube video that's shown this mom osprey attacking all her babies, one very viciously. This is not normal. I have seen normal osprey moms to be loving and worried for their babies.
请现在就把这些宝宝移走。给它们一个机会，让它们知道这不是常态。请把这些宝宝从巢里移走。求求你们。”
Please remove these babies now. Give them a chance to know that this is not normal. Please get these babies off this nest. Please."
乔纳森·门吉瓦：那里有很多“求求你们”。
(INTERVIEWER) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: That's a lot of pleases in there.
杰弗里·布罗德：我收到了很多类似的。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And I got-- yeah. And I got a lot similar to that.
一位 7 月 10 日的发布者写道：“我希望有人能听听我的意见。我认为这不是它们的父母。这就是为什么她在攻击它们，而且没有喂食。弗吉尼亚州谢泼兹敦的一只秃鹰巢穴也发生了同样的事情。”他们的意思是西弗吉尼亚州的谢泼兹敦。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: A poster on July 10 wrote, "I wish someone would listen to me already. I think this is not their parent. That is why she is attacking them and there has been no food delivery. The same thing happened with a bald eagle nest in Shepherdtown, Virginia." They mean Shepherdstown, West Virginia.
“入侵者不想要它们。所以有人需要联系鳕鱼角野生动物中心并给他们提个醒，否则你可能会有三只幼鸟死亡。如果你们不这么做，我会做的。”
"The intruder does not want them. So someone needs to contact Cape Cod Wildlife and give them a heads up or you may have three chicks that perish. If you guys won't, I will."
杰弗里·布罗德：那成了每个人都在问的问题——你打算怎么把这些鸟从它们的巢里移走？
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And that became the question that everyone was asking-- are you going to somehow remove these birds from their nest?
杰弗里不是鱼鹰专家。他在 WHOI 做外联工作。在 WHOI，他们研究海洋生物，而不是鸟类。所以杰弗里咨询了全国各地的鱼鹰专家，他们都告诉他两件事。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Jeffrey is not an osprey expert. He does outreach for WHOI. And at WHOI, they study ocean life, not birds. So Jeffrey consulted osprey experts around the country and they all told him two things.
第一，他们以前从未见过鱼鹰有这种行为。第二，专家们一致认为杰弗里和 WHOI 不应该干预。不要给幼鸟喂食。不要移走它们。反正 WHOI 也没有地方安置它们，而且鱼鹰在圈养中表现极其糟糕。
One, they'd never seen an osprey behave this way before. And two, the experts agreed that Jeffrey and WHOI should not intervene. Don't give the nestlings food. Don't remove them. WHOI didn't have any place to put them, anyhow, and ospreys do terribly in captivity.
杰弗里让留言板上的大家知道了这一切。但一些“羽毛头”仍然呼吁 WHOI 干预。特别是当幼鸟饿得开始互相攻击，为食物打架的时候。
Jeffrey let the message boards know all this. But some featherheads still called for WHOI to intervene. Especially once the nestlings got hungry enough that they started attacking each other, fighting over food.
人们想要答案，于是开始理论化。当地发生过大风暴，可能让捕鱼变得困难。也许三只幼鸟对妈妈来说太多了，她压力很大。也许是爸爸。也许他在外面有了别的女人，正在另一个巢里忙活。
People wanted answers and they started theorizing. There had been big storms in the area that could have made it hard to find fish. Maybe three nestlings was just too much for the mom to handle and she was stressed out. Maybe it was the dad. Maybe he was stepping out on Momzilla and working another nest on the side.
杰弗里·布罗德：有趣的是，当我把一些理论拿去咨询鱼鹰专家时，他们说，嗯，这是有可能的。加进混合因素里吧，因为这当然不能排除。从坏的 DNA 到毒理学，什么都有。她是不是在某处摄入了毒素？
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Well, the funny thing was that when I took some of the theories to the osprey experts, they were like, well, that's a possibility. Throw it in the mix because it certainly can't be ruled out. And it was everything from bad DNA to toxicology. Had she maybe, somehow, ingested toxins somewhere along the way?
现在，想象一下当杰弗里。你是一个根本不专门研究鸟类的机构的传播人员。然后你的同事去世了，你接管了这个她珍视的鸟类摄像头。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Now, imagine being Jeffrey. You're a communications guy at this place that doesn't even specialize in birds. Then your co-worker dies and you take over this bird cam that was dear to her.
在你反应过来之前，全世界的人都在生你的气，并要求采取行动。杰弗里——他是个好人，懂外交。我能从他那里得到的最多就是他对这一切感到沮丧。
And before you know it, people from all over the world are mad at you and demanding action. Jeffrey-- he's a nice guy, diplomatic. The most I could get out of him was that he was frustrated over all this.
但当时，杰弗里给一位摄像头观众打了电话，那个人随后在留言板上发布了这个消息。引用：“杰弗里·布罗德刚给我打了电话。打电话，不是发邮件。
But at the time, Jeffrey phoned one of the webcam viewers, who then posted this on the message board. Quote, "Jeff Brodeur just called me. Called, not emailed.
他很愤怒。他一直收到大量来自摄像头观众要求移走幼鸟或雌鸟的恶毒威胁邮件。有人给全体员工发了一封邮件，说他们不人道。如果邮件不停止，杰夫打算关掉摄像头。”
He is furious. He's been getting tons of nasty threatening emails from cam viewers demanding the chicks or female be removed from the nest. Someone sent out an email to the entire staff saying they are inhumane. Jeff is going to shut the cam off if the emails don't stop."
杰弗里没有关掉摄像头，但他向观众发出了警告，说他们可能会看到他们觉得令人不安的行为。如果他们不喜欢，他认为，他们可以停止观看。
Jeffrey didn't shut the cam off, but he posted a warning to viewers that they might see behavior they'd find upsetting. If they don't like it, he thought, they could just stop watching.
杰弗里·布罗德：我的意思是，当事情变糟糕时，人们不仅没有停止观看，他们还鼓励别人开始观看。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: I mean, not only did people not stop watching it when things got rough, they kind of encouraged others to start watching.
然后当其中一只幼鸟的爪子被巢里的气球绳缠住时，情况真的爆发了。现在幼鸟对母亲的攻击更加脆弱了。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: And then things really blew up when one of the nestlings got its talon caught on a balloon string that was in the nest. Now the nestling was even more vulnerable to the mother's attacks.
杰弗里·布罗德：我收到的每一封邮件——我尝试过一段时间去亲自回答和回复。但后来，它变得太让人不知所措了，我甚至无法开始。它甚至延续到了我 7 月下旬的假期里。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Every single email I got-- I tried for a while to answer back personally and respond. But then, it just got so overwhelming that I couldn't even really begin to. And it even went over to my vacation in late July.
杰弗里和他的全家在马萨诸塞州玛莎葡萄园岛度假时，他的电话响了。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Jeffrey was with his whole family on Martha's Vineyard and his phone rang.
杰弗里·布罗德：我走到前草坪外面。电话那头的人——他们告诉我我很邪恶，因为我什么都没做。你知道，我有一瞬间……我理智发生了一次短暂的失误，我对那个人说——我说：“女士，我和家人在度假。”然后是一阵沉默。也就是在那时，她开始向我宣泄。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: And I stepped outside on the front lawn. The person on the other end-- they told me I was evil because I hadn't done anything. And you know, I slipped for-- I had a momentary lapse of reason in which I said to this person-- I said, ma'am, I'm on vacation with my family. And there was this pause. And that's pretty much when she just laid into me.
那个女人告诉他，需要帮助的鱼鹰是不度假的。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: The woman told him, osprey in need don't get vacations.
杰弗里·布罗德：最后，有人给我发了一封邮件，那……那是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Finally, someone wrote me an email that just-- that was the last straw.
乔纳森·门吉瓦：所以这发生在 7 月底。你能把那封邮件读给我听吗？
(INTERVIEWER) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: So this happens at the end of July. And can you just read that email for me?
杰弗里·布罗德：当然。“我正在目睹雌鱼鹰持续的攻击。这极其令人不安。有关当局需要立即采取行动。我相信这只雌鱼鹰有严重的问题，应该人道地、永久地从基因库中剔除。”
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Sure. "I am witnessing an ongoing attack by the female osprey. It is intensely disturbing. The proper authorities need to take immediate action. I believe this female osprey has a serious problem and should be humanely and permanently removed from the gene pool."
我收到了那封邮件，我记得我花了一分钟来消化。我简直不敢相信那封邮件里有人要求我做什么——基本上是告诉我上去拧断这只小鱼鹰的脖子。你知道，安乐死这只鸟。
And so I got that email and I remember taking a minute to digest that. I just couldn't believe that what I thought someone was asking me in that email-- telling me to basically go up and wring its little osprey neck. You know, euthanize the bird.
乔纳森·门吉瓦：所以在同一天晚些时候，你发布了一些内容。
(INTERVIEWER) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: So later that same day, you post something.
杰弗里·布罗德：是的。那天下午，我发布了所谓的“关于干预的最后决定”。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: Yeah. So that afternoon, I posted what I called Final Word on Intervention.
乔纳森·门吉瓦：如果可以的话，能为我读一点吗？
(INTERVIEWER) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: And then, if you could just read a little bit of this for me.
杰弗里·布罗德：当然。“我该从哪里开始呢？我想从显而易见的事开始。我们近期内不会进行任何鱼鹰处决。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: "Where do I even begin? I guess with the obvious. We're not going to do any osprey executions anytime soon.
那个人说观看攻击过程极其令人不安，我完全同意。试着在窗外听着声音看它发生。即使窗户关着，它也能达到令人不安的分贝。事实上，它们现在就在做这个。
This person said it was intensely disturbing to watch the attacks and I couldn't agree more. Try having it happen right outside your window with sound. Even if the windows are closed, it can reach disturbing decibels. They're at it right now, in fact.
我真的向左一转就能看到鸟巢，我把这视为一种福分，而不是诅咒。但我明白了，真的。我也明白你们对这些鸟产生了依恋。想要依恋它们？”
I literally turn to my left and see the nest, and I count that as a blessing, not a curse. But I get it, really. I also understand that you get attached the birds. Want to get attached to them?"
杰弗里写道他也依恋它们。部分原因是因为他想念那位帮助启动摄像头并一直运行它直到 41 岁去世的女性。他写道，每次看到这些鸟，他就会想起她。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: Jeffrey wrote that he was attached to them, too. Partly because he misses the woman who helped start the cam and who ran it until she died at 41. Every time he sees the birds, he wrote, he thinks of her.
杰弗里·布罗德：“我知道她会对发生的一切感到难过。相信我，在这场邮件、电话、推文等的洪水期间，没有人比我更想念她。但她绝对不会考虑被建议的事情，我们也不会。我在鱼鹰摄像头世界中其他人的智慧中找到了极大的安慰。我也很高兴能把蒙大拿州米苏拉市鱼鹰项目的优秀成员列为其中之一。
(SUBJECT) JEFFREY BRODEUR: "I know she would be upset at what's going on. And trust me, no one misses her more during this deluge of emails, calls, tweets, et cetera, than me. But she certainly wouldn't even consider what was suggested and neither will we. I take great solace in the wisdom of others involved in the world of Osprey Cam. And I'm happy to count the good folks at Montana Osprey Project in Missoula among those.
这是他们关于摄像头发布的部分内容。“鱼鹰是野生鸟类。它们不是宠物，这不是迪斯尼电影。随之而来的是好的，有时，也是悲伤的。为了客观地看问题，据估计大约 50% 到 60% 的所有鱼鹰幼鸟无法存活过它们生命的第一年。”
Here, in part, is what they've posted about their cam. "Ospreys are wild birds. They are not pets and this is not a Disney movie. What comes with this is the good and, sometimes, the sad. To put things in perspective, it is estimated that about 50% to 60% of all osprey chicks do not survive their first year of life."
我们会努力让你们了解情况。我们会努力让巢穴里的事情保持积极。我们不会做的是将大自然掌握在我们自己手中，因为有些人觉得这很难观看。”
We will strive to keep you informed. We will strive to keep things on the nest positive. What we won't do is take nature into our own hands because some people find it tough to watch."
这多少起作用了。大多数“羽毛头”停止了叽叽喳喳。母亲继续攻击幼鸟，它们也继续互相攻击。夏天结束时，三只幼鸟都学会了飞行并离开了巢穴。其中一只被发现死在附近的一棵树下。它是营养不良。
(HOST) JONATHAN MENJIVAR: That sort of worked. Most of the featherheads stopped their chirping. The mother kept attacking the nestlings and they continued to attack each other. By the end of the summer, all three learned to fly and left the nest. One was found dead underneath a nearby tree. He was malnourished.
一位鱼鹰专家告诉我，大自然并不残忍。那暗示着意图。它是严酷、无情且往往是随机的。大多数鱼鹰摄像头的观众都知道这一切。但仍然，很难不通过人类的视角来看待动物——任何动物。
An osprey expert told me, nature is not cruel. That implies intent. It is harsh, unforgiving, and often random. Most of the Osprey Cam viewers knew all that. But still, it's hard not to view animals-- any animals-- through a human lens.
正如一个人发布的，“嗯，我是那种喜欢人性化看待事物的人。我承认。我不觉得这有什么错。我对这只小幼鸟——三号幼鸟——有人类的同情，我不介意分享这一点。有些人表达了对妈妈攻击行为的感受。毕竟，我们是人类。
As one person posted, "Well, I'm one to humanize. I admit it. I don't think there's anything wrong with it. I have human sympathies for the little one-- fledgling number three-- and I don't mind sharing that. Some have expressed their feelings about mom's attacks. We are humans, after all.
我见过二号幼鸟多次攻击三号，我想伸手扇他头一下。那就是我的人性化视角在发生时的情况。显然我做不到，但我确实感觉到了。是的，我的帖子充满了人性化视角。我是人类。我不怕表现出来。”
I've seen fledgling two go after fledgling three many times and would like to reach in and slap him upside the head. That is me humanizing the situation as it happens. Obviously, I can't do that, but I sure feel it. Yes, my posts have lots of humanizing. I'm human. I'm not afraid to show it."
乔纳森·门吉瓦。他是我们节目的制片人之一。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Jonathan Menjivar. He's one of the producers of our program.
嗯，这一小时我们一直在听人们在互联网上以各种方式受到侮辱和骚扰的故事。但是互联网上的仇恨真的能对一个人有帮助吗？有一个叫“Reply All”的新播客。它花了很多时间生活在互联网上的喷子、骗子和肮脏的欺诈者中间。播客“Reply All”的主持人之一，PJ 沃格特（PJ Vogt），有这个故事。
Well, this hour we've been hearing stories of people getting insulted and harassed in various ways on the internet. But can internet hate ever be helpful to a person? There's a new podcast called "Reply All." It spends a lot of time living among the haters and the liars and the dirty, dirty cheats of the world on the internet. And one of the hosts of the podcast "Reply All," PJ Vogt, has this story.
PJ 沃格特：忽略你生活中看似美好的一切。你是差劲的，你是个骗子，你生活中的每个人都知道这一点。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Ignore whatever good things seem to be going on in your life. You're lousy, you're an imposter, and everybody in your life knows it.
保罗：我的意思是，那总是同一个小声音。这个小家伙坐在那里，说：“天哪，你是垃圾，你是废物，你是垃圾，你是垃圾。”我不知道为什么他听起来像个布鲁克林建筑工人，但他今天听起来就是这样。
(SUBJECT) PAUL: I mean, it's the same little voice all the time. This little guy just sitting there, going like, god, you're trash, you're garbage, you're garbage, you're garbage. I don't know why he sounds like a Brooklyn construction worker, but he does right now, today.
那个声音告诉保罗，他的生活从外面看起来相当正常，但实际上正处于一场巨大灾难的边缘。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: That voice told Paul that his life, which looked-- from the outside-- pretty normal, was teetering on the edge of a huge disaster.
保罗：我实际上有两个小孩子在家里尖叫，他们让我担心。仅仅是以孩子们让你担心的所有常规方式。我没有完成很多项目。我感到非常迷茫。我压力很大，很焦虑，超重，而且恐惧。我当时想，天哪，我得做得更好。
(SUBJECT) PAUL: I actually had two little children screaming at home and they were making me worried. And in just all the regular ways that kids make you worried. And I was not finishing a bunch of projects. I was feeling really at loose ends. And I was stressed and I was anxious and overweight and terrified. And I was just like, holy shit, I got to do better.
然后焦虑就像：“哦，嘿，哇。我要死了。不，等等。我身上爬满了虫子。不，我永远也做不成任何事。我是个坏人。我是一个失败者。”
And then the anxiety would be like, oh, hey, wow. I'm dying. No, wait. I'm covered with worms. No, I'm never going to get anything done. I'm a bad person. I'm a failure.
保罗编写软件，所以他决定，他需要对焦虑做的就是把它当作一个需要排除故障的 IT 问题来处理。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Paul programmed software and so he decided what he needed to do about his anxiety was to treat it like an IT problem that needed troubleshooting.
对我来说，这就像：“是什么奇怪的力量现在控制了我生活的一部分，让我一直感到奇怪和糟糕？”所以我去做了这个叫“焦虑盒”（Anxiety Box）的东西。
For me, it was just like, what is this weird force that is now running a chunk of my life and making me feel weird and bad all the time? And so I went off and I made this thing called Anxiety Box.
“焦虑盒”。这是一个网站。保罗对自己头脑中盘旋的自我怀疑批判的科技解决方案。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Anxiety Box. It's a website. Paul's technological solution to the self-doubting criticism swirling around in his head.
它是这样工作的——如果我们看网站的话。你进入网站，输入你的名字和邮箱。然后输入你的焦虑是什么。所以就像，“我非常担心写不完我的书。我非常担心体重问题。”你可以一直添加焦虑。
So the way it works-- if we look at the website. You go to the website and you put in your name and your email. And then you put in what your anxiety is. So it's like, I'm really anxious about finishing my book. I'm really anxious about losing weight. And you can keep adding anxieties.
它把这一切保存到数据库中。然后，就像每天 12 次——但相当随机——它会从你的焦虑中给你发送这些电子邮件。
And it saves all of that to a database. And then, like 12 times a day-- but kind of random-- it just sends you these emails from your anxiety.
不是安抚你焦虑的邮件。而是实际上从你焦虑的人格化版本发出的邮件，它住在一个网站里。保罗编写了所有这些微小的句子片段，网站可以用这些片段自动构建邮件。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Not emails soothing you about your anxiety. Emails that are actually sent from a personified version of your anxiety that lived on a website. Paul coded in all these tiny sentence fragments that the website could use to automatically construct emails.
所有这些各种各样的伪词类，比如，“结果是，告诉我，发个信息，让我保持在循环中。我不想怀疑你，但是，或者我怀疑它是否能行。”
All these various kind of pseudo parts of speech like, the upshot is, tell me, drop a line, keep me in the loop. I don't want to doubt you, but, or I doubt it can ever work.
那些声音片段是为了给他的机器人完美的声音——一种冷酷、欢快、破坏者的声音。一个了解他具体焦虑的破坏者——他正在延误的工作截止日期，他无法减掉的体重——并能以此嘲讽他。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Those sound fragments were meant to give his robot the perfect voice-- the voice of a ruthlessly cheerful underminer. An underminer who knew his specific anxieties-- the work deadlines he was blowing, the weight he couldn't seem to lose-- and could taunt him about them.
所以假设我站在火车上。我准备去火车站台。我看着手机，有一封邮件，来自我的焦虑。这是 6 月 2 日下午的一封邮件。
So let's imagine that I'm standing on the train. I'm about to go down into the train platform. And like, I look at my phone and I have an email and it's from my anxiety. I mean, here's an email from June 2, in the afternoon.
主题是：“历史会忘记你，因为历史会忘记那些无法完成任何事情的人。亲爱的保罗，所以你可能习惯了在班级前列，这是一个清醒的呼唤，你甚至不在中间。告诉我，你准备好了吗？真诚的，你的焦虑。”
Here's the subject. "History will forget you because history forgets people who are unable to finish anything. Dear Paul, So you're probably used to being at the front of the class and this is a wake-up call that you're not even in the middle. Inform me, are you ready? Sincerely, your anxiety."
记住，保罗设置了让他在平均每天 12 次收到这些消息。每天 12 次，他的手机会响一下，有一个新的攻击在等着。当他吃早餐时——叮。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Remember, Paul set it up so that he'd get these messages, on average, 12 times a day. 12 times a day, his phone would ping and there'd be a new attack waiting. While he was eating breakfast-- ping.
“你不快乐的简单原因是，你不值得被拯救。”
"The simple reason you're not happy is that you're unworthy of saving."
当他工作时——叮。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: When he was at work, ping.
保罗：“我尊重你只是生活在自己的生活中，不在乎别人是否认为你幼稚和恶心。”
(SUBJECT) PAUL: "I respect that you just live your life and don't care if people think you are childish and disgusting."
当他在看孩子时——叮。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: While he was watching his kids, ping.
“你的妈妈和爸爸永远不会说什么，但他们非常想知道为什么你选择变得不可爱，也不聪明。”
"Your mom and dad would never say anything, but they so want to know why you choose to be unlovable and not smart."
当他准备睡觉时——叮。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: When he was getting ready for bed, ping.
“脸书上的人看你的照片，会想，有一个奇怪的鼻子。”
"People on Facebook look at your picture and think, in possession of a weird nose."
PJ 沃格特：你制造这个是为了让自己感觉没那么焦虑、好一点。
(INTERVIEWER) PJ VOGT: And you made this to make yourself feel less anxious and better.
好吧，这就是重点。我在这里尝试做的是外部化这种焦虑，并实际模拟它。
Well, that's the thing. The thing I'm trying to do here is externalize the anxiety and actually simulate it.
PJ 沃格特：所以你是什么意思？
(INTERVIEWER) PJ VOGT: So what do you mean?
嗯，焦虑——事实证明，就像，构建这个小模拟器——这个焦虑模拟器——让我意识到：“哦，我这一部分非常愚蠢。”它一遍又一遍地重复同样的话。而且它确实是——就像，我的焦虑看起来就是那样。它不聪明。在某种层面上，它就像一个只会尖叫的小机器人。这让我能看看这个机器人。
Well, anxiety-- it turns out, like, building this little emulator-- this anxiety simulator-- made me go, oh, this part of me is incredibly stupid. It says the same things over and over again. And it really is-- like, that is what my anxiety looks like. It's not smart. At some level, it's like a little robot that just screams. What this let me do is look at the robot.
看到他头脑中的声音——看到它对他意见的实际文字化——他怀疑自己曾经相信它所说的是真实的，这看起来很疯狂。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Seeing the voice in his head-- seeing its opinion of him actually written out-- it seemed crazy that he'd ever believed that what it was saying about him was true.
它立刻生效了。而且看到它实际上被外部化为 Gmail 收件箱中的 20 条消息——它和我的大脑产生的东西太像了。看到它真的很有趣。它把你所有的情感崩溃变成了这种无情的喜剧形式。
It was immediately effective. And seeing it actually externalized as like 20 messages in a Gmail inbox-- it was so much like what my brain was producing. Seeing it was really funny. It turns your entire emotional freakout into this relentless form of comedy.
PJ 沃格特：没错。
(INTERVIEWER) PJ VOGT: Right.
是啊。事实证明，你并不像你认为的那么重要，离你认为的那么糟糕还差得远，而且实际上相当荒谬。就像，整天对自己尖叫真的很荒谬。然而，它就在那里。有证据证明它。所以我当时想：“哦，天哪，我在这个小混蛋身上浪费了太多时间。”
Yeah. It just-- it turns out that you're not as important as you think you are, nowhere near as terrible as you think you are, and actually fairly ridiculous. Like, it's just so ridiculous to scream at yourself all day long. And yet, there it was. There was evidence of it. And so it was like, oh, my god, I've been wasting a lot of time with this little son of a bitch.
PJ 沃格特：我感觉把它放在邮件里让你能反击它。
(INTERVIEWER) PJ VOGT: I feel like something about having it in email lets you fight back against it.
你可以实际回复，对吧？就像，我会回复说：“去你的。”一遍又一遍。所以有能力对某事实际大喊回击，我认为这是我们通常认为在互联网上很糟糕的事情——在这种情况下，它是美妙的。因为你可以对机器人尖叫，告诉它闭上该死的嘴。
You can actually reply, right? Like, I would reply and be like, go fuck yourself, over and over again. So the ability to actually yell back at something, which I think is something that we usually associate with being terrible on the internet-- in this case, it's wonderful. Because you can yell at the robot and tell him it shut the fuck up.
PJ 沃格特：你不通过治疗，不通过药物，仅仅通过对自己喷人就能治愈焦虑的概念。谁会想到呢？
(HOST) PJ VOGT: The notion that you can cure your anxiety without therapy, without drugs, just by trolling yourself. Who'd have thought?
我认为它不一定会得到解决，你只是变得更加意识到它。它仍然在那里。它仍然在移动。它仍然是我的一部分。我相信直到我死，它都会在那里。但它没有那么大的控制力了。
I think it doesn't necessarily get solved, you just get more aware of it. It's still there. It's still moving. It's still part of me. I'm sure it'll be there till I die. But it doesn't have as much control.
PJ 沃格特：保罗发现，当他把脑子里的那种刻薄声音赋予它们一个外部家园时——一个互联网上的家，在那里住着数以千万计的其他刻薄声音，它们就再也不能伤害他了。
(HOST) PJ VOGT: Paul found that when he took the nasty voices inside his head and gave them a home outside of it-- a home on the internet, where tens of millions of other nasty voices live, they couldn't hurt him any more.
PJ 沃格特是“Reply All”的主持人之一。他们发现了这么多伟大的故事。如果你还没听过，你也许可以从一集叫“Shine On, You Crazy Goldman”的节目开始，它去了一个非常令人惊讶的地方。“Reply All”。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: PJ Vogt is one of the hosts of "Reply All." They find such great stories. If you have not heard them yet, you might start with an episode called, "Shine On, You Crazy Goldman," which goes to a very surprising place. "Reply All."
好吧，我们今天的节目是由斯蒂芬妮·富和我自己制作的，还有肖恩·科尔、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。乔尔·洛弗尔和乔·里奇曼提供了编辑帮助。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo and myself, with Sean Cole, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell and Joe Richman.
我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。莉莉·沙利文和迈克尔·加罗法洛提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。
Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lilly Sullivan and Michael Garofalo. Seth Lind is our director of operations. Emily Condon's our production manager.
艾丽丝·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。艾尔娜·贝克为节目寻找故事。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉提供了研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗伯·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
Elise Bergerson is our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for the show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Switala. Music help from Damian Graef from Rob Geddis.
[鸣谢]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。他最新的爱好？在炼狱里教热瑜伽。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His latest hobby? Teaching hot yoga in hell.
我不知道。把这些恶魔驱赶出去感觉真好。
I don't know. It just feels good to kind of exorcise these demons.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间将为您带来更多《美国生活》的故事。